وبالحديث عن الصين والامن الحروب تخلع
تدريجيا عباءه المواجهه التقليديه التي
تخيطها قوه الاسلحه وسرعه الدبابات في ظل
تطور تكنولوجيا وعلميا مخيف معارك صامته
ومواجهته شفرات لا دمويه سيناريو متوقعه
للصراع او حرب مقبله قد تندلع بين واشنطن
وبكين عنوانه العريض التخريب الالكتروني
والهجمات السيبرانيه ففي وقت انقلبت سيدات
السماء او المسيرات الانتحاريه قواعد
اللعبه في حرب اوكرانيا يتوقع ان تهجر اي
حرب مفترضه بين الجانبين الاجواء العاليه
لتتغلغل في البنيه التحتيه التوتر
المتصاعد بين البلدين دفع مسؤولين في مجال
الامن الالكتروني الى التحذير من عمل
قراصنه صينيين على تعطيل البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه في الولايات المتحده مثل خطوط
الانابيب والسكك الحديديه التهديد وصف
بالحقيقي نسيم نبكين توجه استثمارات ضخمه
لتعزيز حجم قدرات الموارد والجهود التي
تبذلها من اجل ذلك لا بل تبرز حاجه ضروريه
لاستعداد لهو التركيز عليه وتطوير قدره
على مجابهته للحد من اضراره في العالم
المادي والحيلولا دون احداثه الاضطرابات
اذا تحضيرات مماثله اطلقتها دوائر
استخباراتيه امريكيه عن دراسه بكين
بالتاكيد لعمليات الكترونيه عدوانيه ضد
البنيه التحتيه الحيويه الامريكيه وضد
اهداف عسكريه في حال استشعر صناع القرار
الصينيين بمعركه وشيكا كما ارتفعت خلال
الاشهر الماضيه حده الاتهامات الامريكيه
لبكين بشن حملات تجسس بمختلف الاشكال
والوسائل على مرافق امريكيه حساسه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات